all right good to be here today good to
be with you alive
we are living here in time
and i got some sage actually
a little bit of sage right here i just
lit it
they say it wards off the devil and
everybody anybody like that
you know frankenstein everybody
damn i let that hot batch fam
pg baby ptl you know it
and this stuff when we didn't have uh
marijuana we used to hit this [ __ ]
pretty hard man
i mean i i didn't get high of a damn i'd
be at peace i remember being at peace
for all the entire
uh seventh grade because of that damn i
can't get it to go out
i pour some of this liquid death on it
that'll help there we go
um good to be
here good to be alive and shout out
sage lanniker
out sage atlantica they had a man in our
town
when i was young you know i wasn't i was
a child and
and there were people that were older
and some of those were men and
and this fella sage this gentleman was
uh
he i guess had a if you he would
sometimes he would torch some of his own
body hair
with a lighter or you know maybe a
not a candle usually just a lighter
and um and it would kind of purify the
room it had the same
audio uh
as a burning actual sage so i remember
sometime at a party
you know if people wanted to kind of set
the mood or if people wanted to get
kind of um native american
they'd torch a little bit of his arm
hair or burn up into his armpit and
really
just pacify the crowd like that so
praise god man
ah what's up
i'm alive isn't it weird
isn't it weird to just you wake up and
you're
just alive again you know
but you keep going at it happy march
that's one thing i can say to you
and we are coming up on springtime
and so it's a you know you can feel a
core of it starting to disappear you can
feel people having freedom and you know
they're starting to have counties around
um
america that the they're open
no masks you start to hear it
it's happening
i guess i don't know what to think but
thinking doesn't usually get me anywhere
anyway so maybe i shouldn't do it
what i do know though is that uh you
should be careful what you put in your
body
and for an all organic alternative to
five hour energy
that gets you into the flow state try
magic mind magic mind
it's an alternative to coffee
go to magicmind.co promo code theo magic
for 20 off
let's get into the episode
there we go
[Music]
this is matthew casio runs in the family
can't save my soul
come on matthew it's just a matter of
[Music]
time
and some real strong lyrical component
right there that's matthew casio runs
in the family can't wash the sin
from the hands that made me
can't outrun what runs
in the family
it's you know i was i was i was actually
thinking the other day
which would shock many but um
i wonder sometimes if we
if like our dna has the pains of
our ancestors in it
you know just as much as you could have
the
ability of a you know say your great
great grandpappy or grandfather
which is a way more appropriate name
a great great grand pappy sound it
sounds like somebody who has no enamel
in their mouth
you know tongue only one of them to bad
boys you know
kind of guy will just inject damn uh
nicotine right into his tongue and just
chew on that [ __ ]
but um i was saying uh
yeah i wonder like our you know our dna
can carry you know if you have a child
it might have blue eyes or
or green eyes or red eyes or something
based on what the parents have
and i was just wondering well what if
you're you know what if your
great-great-grandfather was
you know something happened to him
and does that get stored into your dna
almost like
undeveloped film
and sometimes maybe it takes a
generation or two for it to
you know mature enough or dissipate
enough and
and it affects you somehow
you know i wonder like say if somebody
tickled your great-great-grandmother
but she was in a coma or something
you know when she died you know she was
in a crazy accident with a uh
something simple like a hillside and a
wagon wheel
you know there wasn't a lot of hopper of
unique accidents back then
so she would you know run away wagon
wheel knocked her down a hillside she
was in a coma
for two years and people would take you
know it's one of her nephew her little
cousins or somebody
an intern or some pervert or somebody
would come in and tickle her
at night just kind of getting off on the
fact that you could tickle
a cut that tickle the comatose
without any recourse without even
hearing a giggle but knowing that that
tickle was getting
stored into her body into her frame into
the minutia of her
you know into the textiles into the damn
just the fabric of her whoever she was
and then she died she died in the coma
which happened all the time you
i mean it when you were in a coma a long
time ago people
really thought you were kind of hanging
out with god but your body was still
here so they'd come and people would you
know hey give this to god slip you a
little note
you know hey give god made god a little
bit of apple cider
they slip a jug under your limp arm
you know hey tell god i'm trying to do
these new hats you know they put a
cap on you then you're jugged up you're
capped up
you got hidden giggles in your body
because the
night manager's been tickling you
and then i just wonder if you know
do you have a grandchild or a great
grandchild just that just gets the
giggles
for no reason you know or
you know i just wonder what the
oh i just wonder sometimes like if the
things i'm feeling or thinking are
or doing even
are dreams that maybe a great great
grandfather
had or or
things that happened to them or
experiences or
fears or i just wonder sometimes like um
you know how much of that how much of
the experiences of our
ancestors are in locked into the dna of
us
you know um
and even groups of people you know
certain ethnicities and
and you know how much how much of the
travesty of some histories are locked
into the people
and it takes a while to dissipate
and the fall off of their you know fall
off of the core of their
of their being kind of deal i don't know
i'm kind of rambling now but um
what's going on i'm happy to be alive um
[Music]
you know i uh what did i do
oh we have travis tritt coming onto the
podcast if you ever got an erection
to a ballad um
during the 90s or 2000s it could have
been to a travis tritt
song at a dance
dude i remember god about after
i was always the kid at the dance who
like got set up with somebody
you know and so you weren't it wasn't
like a little girlfriend so it was just
like
yeah you know okay i'm with emily or i'm
with you know
larissa and you kind you were kind of
excited but you knew that they weren't
like
into you so but you kind of hoped
secretly
you know and i remember i go to the
dance and
you do it you know you they had the
obligatory like
you had to kind of slow dance with your
date but then after that
you could kind of freewheel it a little
and now i remember when some of the slow
songs that would come on man i would get
this
this one girl had like a damn
i want to say it was like a huge belly
button like i mean
like a dang just like a little bowl like
a belly bowl
you know just inverted and and if you
were
i was spry you know when a at a dance
man i would get just
just just wait just spring and bone
i had that 35th rib baby just peeking
right up out of the middle of my body
baby
you know what i'm saying my freaking
[ __ ] was just gyrating around you know
what i'm saying baby
you know what i'm saying to you
you know i was spry i was ready i was
procreational i was just
you know god had wound me up and let me
go and i was looking to just spray out
and sometimes i would dance with her and
i remember she she was like
i don't know she didn't have any feeling
in her stomach or anything but you could
like literally
put your just press your damn
just press your just your
[ __ ] junk right up just
right up just smash it
and it was just like wise men
say only fools rushing
it was just a ballad would go on you
know
and you were just god
what just like the world was thirsty for
the sauce you had inside of your wiener
that's what it felt like
like the world just was just that's what
it felt like being young it felt like
the entire universe was constantly just
sucking at your pee pee
but those were the days man that is
runs in the family by matthew
kazial um
what's happening um
what's going on um i need to get some
pants i i don't like
shopping i don't like i don't
like i want to make a goal this year to
shop
more from um
smaller brands you know hometown places
i've been wanting to get a blender for
the past month so i'm going to try to
find a
locale electronics dealership
go in there test the models
there'll be a guy in there like hey hey
i'm wrong
oh yeah that's smoothies yeah this was
smoothies
this one oh [ __ ]
oh yeah you got a newborn he's giving
him peaches all this one
get this one
you know and i'll listen to the [ __ ]
for a bit
before i say look ron i'll take it all
right just
you just shut up can you do it
um what i see the original uh mr potato
head
they change the name to
just potato or something let me see what
it says
the uh the mr potato head
article yeah it said mr potato head is
now just gonna be potato
head that's the thing
a gender neutral version of the toy
they will be offering a general neutral
version of the toy alongside the
traditional oh so they're keeping the mr
and misses
potato head
um and people was uh some people were
upset about i don't think the people
were that upset about it but
and they said they say online
which is basically a dangerous place to
be if you like to have any peace in your
life
um but i was thinking like
well a potato first of all is male they
have male and female characteristics in
it
so you got to know they are self
pollinators i have this article say
meaning that every individual potato
plant possesses both male and female
flowers for reproduction so a potato has
already got that dual citizenship
you know when it comes to crotch
um so yeah why not
why not again what my question is what
what
what kid still wants to play with a
potato
you can't get a kid excited by giving
them a damn bow tie anymore
so that kid's not even mentally well
let's be honest
that kid probably has a little bit hit
of uh
give me a t give me an eye give me an s
give me an m baptism
you know it and i grew up heavy in the
autism world
we had a kid at the end of our block and
he really he had just nine different
haircuts man he just
he was kind of just i mean from
everything from cornrow to damn
fade to military to damn
you know he had that kind of action
gospel cut they thought he could sing he
couldn't sing
he was mentally challenged you know and
and they put him on the front porch and
he would sing uh
ac dc lyrics and
you know and just kind of cheer at the
cars when they went by and i don't know
what happened to him
and i would probably guess death if i
had to guess something
i don't know if i would guess death but
i would draw out of a hat
see if there was a hat full of things
and it's that had happened to him
and everybody had written on a car what
happened to him i would draw a card out
of there and i bet most of the cards
would probably say deceased
and bless him bro praise god but um one
of my [ __ ] i'm
i'm all over the place um
yeah what kid wants to play with a
potato now who cares
i don't care if the potato dude this
that's not a real mr potato mr potato is
a man
he's a grown man he got his feet out
like that he got some mustache
glasses he kind of looks like he
probably did a crime and now he's hiding
you know he looks a little polish but
maybe also
kind of urban bro you know kind of
afro-polish maybe if you look at him
basic you know
if he's that kind of idaho kind of gold
you know
but now if they want a potato that got
you know both
you know that's not a real that's not mr
potato they got a new thing
they got that dual crotch rusted they
got that dual crotch rusted fam
and that's chill just say that
like i think some of the articling
is just to create a stir just say look
we got that dcr baby all right
we got you know what i'm saying poppy
mommy got that mixed bag
but what kid is still playing with a
potato
i can't you can i you can't i don't know
one kid you can get off his ipad long
enough to even discuss a vegetable
all kids want to know now in days is is
elon musk
their dad is elon musk my dad
that and if the answer is no then there
but they don't
it's that's it the rest of their lives
they'll spend in therapy wishing he was
that's all that's it is he on mars my
dad
[Applause]
they don't care what kind of [ __ ]
crotch the vegetable has
if we want to do a toy where they where
they get to discuss
gender let's do operation that way
let the kid build whoever they want
this bobby sue right here he got the
teddy in the root
party on bro you know invite him to the
freaking
varmits for dog let's do it but
let the kid have a say-so in it i think
do
let him let him have operation you got
the mustache
you got that freaking that wild oyster
bro let's do it
that's what i say just let the kid have
a little bit of say so
in in the thing or just do transformers
if you're going to make
something completely open an open toy
do transformers they're having they're
they're kind of asking for it but let
the child or the
have it say so anything or do teddy
ruxpins
dude teddy ruxin he got the cord on the
back yeah
you know well i want waffles
you know i thought i'm supposed to be a
bear
you know do teddy ruxpins he got the
thing on the back
you know man won't you be my friend
you know my my penis has ovaries
but i'm only five who who wants to see
my menstrual cycle
let the animal or the kid have a say-so
in it
that's what i think
that's but what also what do i know i'm
not a child
if it if you see me shopping for toys
for kids though
that's an even bigger issue so
when you see people shopping for toys
for children
and they don't have a children with them
and it's december or it's
and it's not december
we got way bigger issues than uh
you know gender gender gen
genders gen hymn gentiles genders
oh man i got to tell you this so i went
and first of all i want to say this too
man i want to thank everybody uh
you know we had an episode last time to
spill the dumplings episode it was kind
of get you know it was it gets emotional
sometimes and that's just who i
am um you know when uh
i just want to thank people just nice
messages and just
people for just being willing to be a
part of this
um just kind of conversations and
things that
i don't know i just want to say thanks
you know thanks for the support
uh and thank you for the just uh just
just it's not even thanks it's just like
look let's do this
you know let's try not to be afraid to
figure out what
where we are and what's going on
you know we there's so many like little
social rules about being alive and our
behaviors and
i just wanna damn be alive man i just
want to
know as much about whatever this is
this experience
and and and and and a lot of you do too
so thank you um
oh i gotta tell you this the uh that's
not a commercial either ah
um i went out the other night so
travis tritt is a folk
country i mean it just
so many songs you may know or your
parents may know oh
so you got to peep that with your ears
and and your face it'll be out this
weekend
um so anyway after the show
after we chatted on the episode
uh we got to go out we went out and
kid rock bob richie
who is an adult man who
you know i love i was thinking about
what did i love about kid rock as a
fan as a listener and i just remember
being
i remember being poor and white and
thinking
he just was able to kind of express the
he was this rap like
i mean it was it wasn't country
it was like rap
rock a bill i want to say rock a bit i
don't know i don't know enough about
music to know the exact
genre and i think it was kind of a new
genre it was just this it was something
i could fit into
you know i mean i or something i could
if i was just like oh here's a guy who
just
is it's like a poor white guy who's
saying
who's who's angry and
brash and i could just relate to a lot
of that [ __ ]
you know uh because the world i grew up
in the environment
that i sprouted through was a crass it
was crass
and it was but it was passionate and it
was
i don't know anyway so um
living my life in a slow hill and when
he did that slowing with sheryl crow
come on boy
come on and she would sing and you'd get
kind of erect a little and then he would
sing you'd have to [ __ ] cover it up
you know
god i mean that was just damn
that was a lot but anyway so we went out
to dinner which was really neat and
uh just to be in the presence of people
that are
telling stories you'll never get to hear
and
um and it was just really it was a good
time but anyway afterwards we went
uh we're out here in the central east
and kid rock has an establishment
bob is his name sorry has an
establishment uh
and it's a domicile for liquor and music
and um so we walked over there from the
restaurant we're at
and dude i've walked with
some heroes right some unique humans
i've walked with criminals i walked with
a buddy of mine that killed somebody
and and he said it felt pretty good
honestly
but um anyway so we're walking down the
street and you start to and it's so it's
just
drunk people right it's like a french
quarter type of vibe when you're walking
down the street and
and you see people just start to notice
bob
and they start to get
i mean people are losing it you know
some guy tried to spell out bob with a
bob at a bang at a bang boogie
he just tried to he started spelling it
out like a police officer had said all
right i need you to recite this
you know some girl threw her ovary at
him
some girl was running for him ran right
into a uh do not park here sign
i see some dude crash his car he's like
some fella drank his own blood put a
thing into his side of him started just
sipping on it dude
just [ __ ] i mean people were
losing their minds and he had like
security but it was
just i mean people were just uh
some woman got down and proposed to her
husband every person every like
space he walked past something insane
would happen
a window shattered a baby in a stroller
probably four months got out of the
stroller and just started walking walked
off his parents are sitting there kind
of hugging
he's i'm out of here i'm going to do my
own thing
i'm looking for my real dad elon musk i
mean it was
just crazy fireworks a dove pulled a
magician out of his hat
he had a hat on he pulled a magician out
the magician was wondering if he was
getting his stimulus payment the bird
flew off
but every moment we went past like
people can rock
rock a caterpillar admitted that he was
just a cat
and it was all just a ruse to meet women
with the long you know
trying to show them that length show
them that body work
um so it was just you know it was just a
fat it was just
because look i've i've ridden in cars
and arrived at places
with people with unique uh with pomp and
circumstance
but to ship but to walk
not a mile or walk one one-fifteenth of
a mile
not in someone's shoes but near
someone's shoes
um it was just it was i don't know it
was just interesting
you know you just it just doesn't happen
uh every day
and certainly not to me um
i'm gonna tell you this though that
if you are selling stuff online
which is a lot of people these days you
know is people say it's dangerous out
there
to have a brook and mortar business you
know because of the core of it people
sneaking in sneezing in your window
somebody call for exhale on your
merchandise
it'll kill a grandmother that's what
they're saying
that's why you need to be in the right
business and you need to
put your business online online
with ship station that's the right
business
orders coming in they need to go out
fast
import orders from any sales channel
shipped with any
carrier no matter where you're selling
amazon etsy
or your own website you know jerk it out
function.com.org
dot tit whatever shipstation funnels all
your orders into one simple interface
that you can manage from anywhere even
your cell phone you see them come in
you send them out you'll get access to
amazing discounts with major carriers
including ups fedex usps
the spca and uh
i've just made a joke on that last one
easily compare carriers and choose the
best solutions every time
with ship stations small businesses can
now access the same rates
reserved for fortune 500 companies
that's important
fight back against the big dog just use
my offer code
t-h-e-o to get a 60-day free trial
that's two months free of no hassle
stress free shipping just go to ship
station dot com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and type in
t-h-e-o that's shipstation.com
enter offer code theo make ship
happen look you know i spoke uh
a decent amount of spanish over my life
but nothing that's really put me to that
next
level nothing where i've ever made love
to a
woman or force any even anyone that was
formerly a woman
because that's my thing man if i was
ever gonna be gay i'd have to at least
say hey well you was at least a woman
once right if you go
full dude bro that's
that might be too much i think for me
for me
but i look if you say look you were a
chick for a couple years right
then you know we can you know we can
enlist at least split it
as hurt anyway
in case you don't speak uh spanish
or german uh you can learn it from babel
the number one selling language learning
app
one of my goals for the new year was to
learn a new language and i haven't done
it
but babel has made the whole process
addictively fun
and easy with bite-sized lessons that
you'll actually use
in the real world babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language
on the go they have practical
real world conversations in mind
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french
italian and german
right now when you purchase a
three-month babel subscription you get
an additional
three months for free that's right
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babble.com
start babbling that espanol
that gentleman
some in the butt just go to babel.com
and use promo code t-h-e-o that's
b-a-b-b-e-l
dot com code theo for an extra three
months
for free babble language for life
we also have new merch now available at
theovon.com
make sure to grab a get that hitter
hoodie
we got some neat colors we have some
neat stuff coming out this year i'm
excited about
uh what else
um you know
we've had a lot of nice calls from you
guys i wanted to make sure that i keep
this going as well
uh you know we we made a
a goal this year to help out some single
moms and do some nice things
so i want to continue that right now
as i sit my liquid death
this is water too if you like if you
it's funny because if you look at the
cane you think it's a
liquor beverage but that's water baby
praise god man um but we want to
continue uh that goal this year and uh
see if we can't holler at somebody right
here
hello hey is karina there
yes this is her hey karina my name is
theo i work on a podcast
um and i think you might have spoken
with my producer nick
um i haven't oh you didn't
no at least i don't remember oh that's
okay
look we've all we've all done some
things i'll tell you that
um do you you work as a corrections
officer
i do sir oh nice and you have two kiddos
right
i sure do i have two boys oh dang boys
are freaking dangerous i think
they are um
are they yeah yeah something's in them i
don't know what's in them
me neither can you tell me
look i have no idea um
well someone called then i i'm sorry i
thought they maybe spoke to you someone
called and just we do a thing
i work on a podcast called this past
weekend and we just do a thing where
you know i was raised by a single mom
and so sometimes we reach out to single
moms and just try and do something nice
so we just wanted to reach out and just
offer you 500 bucks just to go do
something fun with the kiddos whenever
you
uh feel like it so um
oh really yeah okay and you don't have
to do anything
you don't owe us anything um you know
that's it we just want you to go have
just go do something fun with those
freaking deviants
yeah oh wow that's that's really amazing
thank you so much for that
i really appreciate it are they pretty
violent
um no they're pretty calm kids
oh dang yeah they're pretty calm kids
does it help being a corrections officer
does that kind of like if they see you
in uniform does that add like a little
bit of extra edge
it i think so they they tend to listen
more
i think i definitely would look if if my
mom said i'm gonna put you in time out
and she actually meant it like
incarcerated i think i would really
tighten up as well
yes sir absolutely
well karina thanks for being a sweet mom
and whoever i don't even know who it was
that that
that nominated i'm sorry i just don't
have that information but uh
yeah they just said that this lady's
really awesome and that um
yeah and that she would probably like to
do something fun so
i'll have my producer call you back and
just circle up with you
okay all right that sounds great i thank
you so much i thank you for what you're
doing
oh no worries thank you for uh for just
even letting us chat on the phone and i
hope you guys have fun
and look that money can be used for bail
too if those kids are real bad it can be
used for bail
you guys have a good one all right you
too sir
bye-bye karina
that's a pretty name i was thinking if i
could have a spanish name and i don't
know if that's spanish but
i'm going to guess it that it is karina
what does it mean let me look at that up
korina
um maiden
means maiden so karina
is it a spanish name the name karina's
nickname
um karo latin word caught us which means
beloved or
dear oh that's sweet dude that would be
wild bro if your mom goes off to prison
dude she would be able to handle
you easy can you even fathom that
and imagine getting frisked before you
go to bed
that would be insane spread them you
know
you're like i'm just i just brush my
teeth
she says spread him but she just means
your teeth she wants to see if you if
you brushed him or not
that'd be pretty funny uh
the hotline baby praise god maybe ptl
stay ready bro praise god
hit in there um
the hotline as always is 985-664-9503
uh i wanna see what we got on
uh on on the call see what happened man
see what's hitting
let's get into um into some of that here
we go
yo what's up my name is damon calling
you
i live in everett washington dirty damon
up there outside of everett
and i'm sorry for calling you damon but
dirt and sometime with damon they say
dirty damon
you know like claude they say clean
clawed
but they don't say clean damon on we're
brother
um 23 years old uh
i just had a quick question so i wanted
to get your opinion on something
my girlfriend and i have been trying to
spice things up in the bedroom you know
oh yeah brother send pics
just joking don't write an article about
that some creep
um yeah brother i feel you man look
when i was 23 baby doing sex was really
god i mean i felt like i was just
sunbathing on the lord's front porch bro
i mean i just felt like my whole body
[ __ ] knew just
was made out of damn just penis meat man
i was just so
you were just so excited and fired up
god remember that i remember somebody
would just accidentally bump into me and
if
if she was cute i'd damn you know
i'd dampen that leg baby you feel me
onward baby let's hear more brother
thank you for calling man praise god
it's been a while we've been going at it
for a while and
time to try some new things so she
suggested
that we come up with different
characters and act like we're cheating
on each other
but uh the problem is is i'm not very
good at this i mean
i come up with characters and i i either
break character
or i just i don't know don't know what
to say and i think it's been
it's been a while since i've been in the
games you know
hurting and trying to pick up girls
isn't really strong
but uh her she's really good at it i
mean
she's coming up with characters names
right off the bat
playing him really well and i don't know
i just want to be able to give her what
she's given me
so if you got any advice for me uh i
would love it
uh thanks for all you do man love the
podcast gang
see you later bro thank you man um
and thank you for the call and for
asking me uh
i mean that's that's first of all that's
exciting
you're involved in an exciting world
where you guys are
you know dressing up and doing um
different pos you know positions or
something or whatever you know
costume and all of that that's that
booty halloween when they say let's get
you know why don't you do this or do
that
and it's kind of the one time i feel
like if you want to do
i wouldn't say if you want to kind of go
a little brown face you might be able to
do it in that instance
you know if it's just you and your girl
and you want to really kind of
explore some sexual
you know adventures
you know you do something i'm not saying
you know
get racial but i'm saying you know maybe
some nest cafe or something on the
cheeks a little bit of uh
you know i think you could go at least a
mocha
and you know my name is no dante my name
is you know
uh you know corinthian or something you
know you could do
like you could do a role play like that
so
it kind of gives you a chance to
[Music]
learn about other cultures you could
read up on some of
you know a certain culture's history a
black history if you wanted to if you
want to go black and
you know just approach your girl maybe
you know everything we've been through
that kind of stuff
and at least have like a
you know have put on some um
poetic justice or something in the
background or like a um
save the last dance or something or
dances with wolves i'm trying to think
of like a good kind of racially
movie that permit promotes like um
you know racial love you know
so that could be something
uh you could do
swedish you know swedish is kind of easy
you get a thing of milk
a pail of milk and then you run over
there and you all kind of [ __ ] a little
but i'm trying to think of something you
could do that would be more historical
you could maybe do native american
you know and she's like a white woman
and you
you know sneak in or something sneak in
the window
you know you you know you don't attack
or you you know you tell you leave her a
note or something says i'ma attack you
you know plan ahead but you don't just
you don't just
you know not call for a couple days and
then
swing out of the damn cabinets you can't
be like indian in the cupboard you got
to be
you know indian in the closet who left a
note
but i would go full throttle because if
anything the one thing it's going to do
this whole thing is just gonna create
comfortability
so many guys would love for their wife
or their you know fiance their french
wife or whatever
to do a wig you know to do uh
you know you know that crotch wig that
strap on or probably not that but
they would love for their wife to do
something unique
but he's afraid to say it they're just
afraid to say hey honey
put on the green wig borrow wanda's
[ __ ] wig
so for seven seconds of my life it could
feel you know i could feel that vibe
like i'm getting up in that ufo you feel
me praise god man but
also you could um what am i thinking
about i'm just saying
and once you if you're starting to
create communication dude that's fire
because then you guys gonna be able to
do anything
so many of us were just afraid to talk
and say this or say that
we're afraid of the judgment or what
they gonna think or they're gonna tell
people
but man to live outside of that fear
and to dress up like the damn
you know like saving private ryan or
whatever
or you know dress up like damn uh
jean-claude van damme you and your girl
dress up like karate man or something
you know
and just kick each other till you
ejaculate you know there's just
you gotta think big picture fam
so but thank you for that call man
i really appreciate it man um
let's see what else we got here
hey what's up steve you got seth out of
uh
central pennsylvania here seth
out of central pa baby
and that's amish country man that's a
good place to get that uh
you know a strong batch of milk and a
little bit of um
uh peeping tommen
let's hear more just finished up
watching
uh this past weekend number 322.
um i noticed you know a good part of
that you were going in about um
you know how you're having a hard time
like really getting intimate with other
people and loving other people
you know on that on that deeper level
man and i find i
uh oh yeah
i mean when it comes to connection for
me it's oh man it's often it's in the
shallow end of the pool it feels like
especially when it comes in intimacy
i'll be in three feet at the hampton inn
dog you know
praise god baby let's hear more daddy
face first baby
i struggle with that a lot as well and i
feel like a lot of that comes down to
um you know like it's it's hard for me
to trust myself sometimes man and i have
uh
you know i make i make a lot of progress
in my life you know i'm doing well
you know i provide for myself i'm doing
things that make me happy but
you know at the end of the day i just
find it very difficult for
me to trust myself in a lot of things
and i feel like you
i feel like you uh i feel like you can
relate to that to some extent so i guess
the
question i have for you is uh you know
what what do you do
in your own life or rather what could
you do in your own life to
you know build a better relationship
with yourself so you can
you know trust yourself in whatever
situation no matter how bad it gets i
got you brother
much love gang gang gang player
gang man thank you for um for taking the
time to call man
yeah trust in yourself man as you're
talking i'm thinking
one
one thing i do sometimes that doesn't
help me i set a lot of boundary
you know i set a lot of boundary man
like a uh
i mean just like a fence worker i said i
said a lot of strange
rules like i'll go for a run
and at the end i'm like all right man
running every day now next 30 days we're
gonna do it
we're gonna do it i'll reach into a tree
and just grab a raccoon out of it and
just choke it out
did you hear me on stripes
so then now i got this rule and i gotta
run for the next 30 days
then i forget that i have that plan
the next day comes i don't run but my
brain will remind me
man you didn't run hey hi
it waits till i literally lay down you
didn't run did you
or all daddy like hey when are you gonna
run
when you're gonna run huh day two day
two
so i'll let myself down but it's just
cause i make all these rules it'll be
everything
i'll bite into a tomato it's like oh
salad only 30 days
salad all lie jesus
the next morning i wake up and have a
waffle you know
and there's two in a little pack but i
only have one but still
my brain's like oh man no too much for
salad only you know
i guess i'll just be a glutton and just
probably die early you know my
so anyway i start to not trust myself
because i make i constantly make these
different
rules for myself that are impossible
to live up to the number i make of them
are impos there's no
that's called unrealism
so when i do that then i start to not
trust myself because i've made
so many little rules that i've broken
so but i i i never stopped making the
rules so there's no way i could do it
let me hear a little bit more again
about what you asked so i can be clear
on that deeper level man and i find i uh
you know
i struggle with that a lot as well and i
feel like a lot of that comes down to
um you know like it's it's hard for me
to trust myself sometimes man and i have
uh
you know i make i make a lot of progress
in my life you know i'm doing well
you know i provide for myself i'm doing
things that make me happy but
so another place where i have some
issues about trusting myself is um
you know when like i will find this i'll
call like a lot of my friends in
recovery and
one thing that's interesting about
people in recovery
or who have ever been in recovery or
spent time in it
once you once somebody you you connect
with that person you connect with them
on a level
it's a real level it's different than
the other
video game levels you're on with regular
humans
this you straight to bowser
you know so it's uh
there's just a real connection um
so i'll call a lot of my friends a
recovery i will just say hey man am i
am i okay is everything okay
you know just tell me everything's okay
please
i'll do that man i do it three times a
week
hey man i'm okay right i mean out of the
blue
hey alan what's up man hey dicky how are
you dog yeah
i'm dude i just
i'm okay aren't i
so i it's hard i never had i just didn't
have and i'm not
complaining i'm not like upset you know
sometimes i get a little perturbed but
when i was young or whatever happened i
don't know
i just there was never a voice saying
everything's okay
everything's gonna be okay you're okay
you're fine we're fine everything's
gonna be
fine there was a lot of other commotion
where things i didn't know if they were
going to be fine
so then still to this day that's like
there's always still this invisible
commotion
going around all the time
you know so it's hard for me to then
trust myself a lot of times because i
don't even know that everything's okay
so if i go for two or three days without
hearing man it's okay
it's like damn
i start to just not trust myself is like
well how could i can't make any more
decisions right now i don't even know if
everything's okay
so i don't know if that makes any sense
bro but
it's also hard to trust yourself when
you don't even you feel like you don't
know yourself
you know a lot of those spaces make it
so hard to make decisions from
like man if i do this am i gonna be okay
while other people are just doing this
doing that
doing coke juggling not no concerns
just totally [ __ ] ripping full sin
confidence
uh but one of the byproducts is that of
that is that you think
sometimes thinking a lot is helpful it's
nice
your brain can be really kind of
thoughtful at times because you think a
lot
so um and it gets better as you get a
little bit older daddy
i promise you that but the [ __ ] can be
intense i think the one cure for it is
something i haven't enacted
very well in my life and i do believe
that it's meditation
um but also what do i know bro you know
what i'm saying i'm just a semi white
fam
praise god dawg and r.i.p billy conforto
man
you know i got a couple of messages
about him the other day and uh
we're gonna try to get that bench put up
over there
near laplace louisiana
in his hometown where he hit that final
in bank and
and called it quits and got drafted in
the first round by god
um you see in the notes anything else i
wanted to make sure i got to
uh oh if you know a single mom
uh that could use some support
try not to tell her so we can make it a
surprise um
you know i was raised by a single mother
i know that it's tough
i know that money doesn't solve any
problems uh
but i just think sometimes
money's just energy it's just saying he
here's some some energy that came my way
let's put it your way
so just when i think about a mom having
just a little extra spending money to do
something nice for her kiddos
i imagine that makes moms feel real good
you know there's something i've never
had seen this because i don't have any
children's but
you see a parent and they just
see and when their kid is having fun you
see they just
it's almost like they're they're the
remote control
and they put in the right codes or
whatever
and now they're just watching it play
out well or something
so yeah that's really some of the goals
not to
really think we're need or anything it's
just to try and do some little
you know what can we do so them little
boys have a
extra fun day and they don't have to
know what has anything to do with that
they don't know us
them boys ain't podcasting they [ __ ]
looking for the devil
so but if you know one uh hit hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
um we also want to continue our series
of interviews with real hard working
people
with interesting occupations we're
currently searching
for a catholic nun or baptist nun even i
went to last baptist over there off of
uh jefferson
a pest control or animal control worker
and an amish or mennonite
if any of our listeners know someone
they think would be perfect for the
podcast
fill out a contact form at theovon.com
or hit up the voicemail hotline
and thank you guys so much for just
being a part of our lives man
what else oh a seattle woman finds a
kilo of cocaine
in crochet kit she bought at thrift shop
so seattle woman finds one kilo of
cocaine
in a croquet croquet
crotche crochet kit
at thrift shop that
kilo damn dog
at a crochet shop boy call me kilo and
stitch fam
knit me up that gator tail baby we
making booty movies son
come on that albino giraffe neck daddy
you feel me
that dust back lizard fam that chunky
that colombian bam bam
feliz navi damn
call me the power company cause i'm
lit if you find a kilo of cocaine with
some knitting stuff
freaking sew me up a gram mama
okay knit me that hit crochet
me that yay boy i'm talking about knit
that hit
crochet that yay you feel me sew me up a
pile of toot boo boo
all right i'm talking about that
scottish airlines that hollywood
breakfast baby
damn i need to go to goodwill boy
who's your dealer uh goodwill
the woman purchased the kit to crochet
animal hats
animal hats [ __ ] dude i'll be [ __ ]
doing that rhino you dog
that [ __ ] white nose baby you feel me
let's
go
but when the crochet hobbyist opened the
kit she found a suspicious package
that was encased in yellow rubber with
100 percent written on it
the item also gave off an odd odor
odd odor baby that ain't an odd odor
that's that
god otter baby and that thing's trying
to swim up you snout boo boo come on
police did not say how the crochet kit
and narcotics
ended up at the thrift shop well look
unfortunately in america a lot of these
workers
they're under tight schedules and you
know what i'm saying bro
freaking toot me up a scarf baby
wolf me up a damn freaking set of
mittens son
you know it's just you know despair at
times required disparate measures baby
and that's it people doing toot just to
get through a damn afghan brother
you know having women been through
enough man praise god bro
damn so lucky man
we i never found nothing like that i
remember once uh
we got a baby crib for my cousin and
they had a um
house arrest bracelet in it so
but nothing like this i mean this is
just
damn just lucky
just lucky man we can't all be winners
you know that
come on uh
what else do we have going on here let
me see
let's do one more call that came in man
hto it's a guy flynn
what's up flynn named after errol
flynn i'm guessing and errol flynn
played uh
i think he was robin hood in the 1900s
let's hear more i'm just taking a walk
with my dog
it's a frigid 30 degrees we're getting a
little bit of
sleep out here that wannabe snow kind of
thing
oh yeah well look the real snow
obviously is at the damn
thrift shop son you know what i'm saying
bro
gang onward brother thanks for calling
and uh i was just hearing you talking
about how you didn't want to let us down
you know you have some some viewers who
are
in programs that doing rehab or staying
sober trying to stay sober
and you feel like you don't want to let
them down yeah man um
yeah we touched on that on the last solo
episode about uh
drinking and um
and yeah like having a respe not a
responsibility but yeah just feeling
hard to share
and maybe some responsibility um onward
by uh by kind of coming on with your own
with your own failures your own woes and
i just i just wanted to say man that you
don't have to worry about that
we're all here for you you're here for
us it's a little family we got going on
here
um i have anxiety i have tourette's i
have
adhd you know you name it any of the
acronyms that's why we got it
you know what i mean but we're all out
here just doing the best we can
with what we got and i wouldn't fault
yourself for
for uh cutting back or slacking on your
sobriety
as long as you realize that where you
want to be
and where you're going and how that
intersects with
with what you got going on now so just
keep pushing towards that
that positive future keep being you
and keep keeping us in the loop thanks
for everything man have a good one
thanks man uh
well yeah i appreciate that man i
appreciate uh the sentiment
and the call and um and the support um
yeah i just want to do my best to just
be as
i just want to do my best to say to kind
of say what's going on you know i want
to be able to
work from a place of that's kind of as
not as like real as i can just like as
up to date as i can be and
um i don't know but thank you for saying
that man that's nice you to say and uh
and i appreciate it um
[Music]
yeah it's a lot of people's you know
it's just a lot of this stuff kind of
stuff is a journey
you know um
it's just scary man it's so scary when
you see
the kind of stuff that can happen when
people really struggle
and i don't know
i've never thought that i've had
problems with
alcohol um ever
uh but
yeah it's just that risk of getting too
far
uh you know next thing you know you wolf
in tune and you in a damn electric chair
or something
or just a regular chair hell either way
you still just wolfed out on that
freaking
jack london bro you know um
um
and it's just yeah you see people that
get to a wild let you know it's just
i don't know i had a friend that uh
that died the other day
of uh an overdose and that's scary to
hear
you know it's just scary to hear
oh and it's just so
final and you wonder like if you stay in
the best way you can be
what little you know are you more are
you sober enough then
where you make an extra call to a friend
and you don't save their life or nothing
but you just you're one little more
little moment that keeps them
because i get those moments from people
people hey man i
you know a buddy will call and just
check in hey man i'm just calling to let
you know this or
just those little things that like
just get your day into a better space
you know and just those little pieces
that make you feel like people care you
know it's
um and i think a lot of it is we do a
lot of our caring now on social media so
it's not
care that people really feel or
hear or it so it doesn't have that
residual effect i feel like um
as it used to kind of but what do i know
uh but what i do know is i appreciate
your call man
and that's nice you to even think of me
and and to think to call you know yeah i
was kind of scared to talk about it but
um it was scared her to be in a
but also i didn't want to be in a place
where i
uh was kind of
not living a lie i didn't feel like i
was living a lie i just felt like i
just wanted to try and be just
transparent
um what else do we got here man
here we take this what's up the yoyo
little dust bear
hey man what's up this is brady calling
i just moved to salt lake
from colorado a few months ago and um
it's the first time i've been living by
myself it's been
hard to say the least oh yeah living by
yourself is tricky man
because you'll get pissed somebody left
the dishes in the sink um
but it's always you who did it
so um but i've been really struggling
with
my sobriety and uh
especially with kovid you know it's like
it's really hard to find
meetings and um
going to these online meetings isn't the
same
at all so i was just looking for some
tips
you know how do i cope with my
alcoholism
without being able to go to real life
meetings man
i don't know i'm struggling
i've just been drinking a lot and
i know it's not the right thing to do
but
it's easier said than done you know what
i'm saying
anyway i don't want to be a debbie
downer but uh
i love your podcast
thanks brady uh i appreciate it man
you're not a debbie downer dog i mean
you just we do what we can you know
just like the fella that just called in
here man
you know um we just do what we can
you call somebody else you check on them
i cannot believe sometimes that
there hasn't been more of an outrage
from the recovery community
to reinstate meetings in person
you don't have to agree with me but
it is baffling to me the number of
it's baffling to me the connection that
is created through in-person meetings
um and how they're that is not just like
a top story
almost every day of how we are missing
that
throughout this pandemic and i wonder
how many more people
we've lost to addiction
and some of the byproducts of that
and i would bet it rivals
i would bet at rivals i'll tell you this
this is a true statement
i personally know more people
that have overdosed
or relapsed and lost their life
in the past year
than i do people that have lost their
life from covid
that's facts personally no
personally i have four
i have four friends that have lost their
life in the past year from drug and
alcohol relapsing
or use overdosing um
i know one person who
[Music]
uh had covered when they died that's
just me
um
so i i don't know um but anyway man i
didn't mean to
get away from what you're asking for
brady or what you're asking about we
just stick together man look i don't
want those zoo meetings either
they [ __ ] suck but they also suck if
i say that they suck
they also everything sucks if i say that
it sucks
so some of it i have to try and put on
me i gotta find a local guy to spend
time with you know
um i gotta have other people to check in
with
and i need to check in with others
you know a lot of times like i'm going
to call this person my brain will be
like they'll be calling i'll be like
don't answer it dude just do your own
[ __ ]
nah answer it
you know answer it um
you know we lost a comedian uh about a
week ago
and i don't want to talk out of school
he struggled man this guy struggled at a
level that was um
man he struggled
i think he was the
he he was one of the two funniest people
i'd ever seen on stage
kill a crowd or him
and joey diaz kill a crowd
actually i'll add in i'll add in
crystallia and i'll add in earthquake
um kill
really kill a crowd and uh
and his name is eric myers and he
um
and i just say this because i want i
just want his name to be said and i want
it to be heard and
uh he died in texas a week ago he
um apparently relapsed and
was walking on the freeway or the
interstate late at night and was hit by
a vehicle
a van actually jesus oh
getting hit by a car sounds away
actually or getting hit by a vanta
both sound bad actually car sounds worse
happening than van
because van like it's all you know one
point of kind of
um but uh
you know he was supposed to come on here
a couple months ago he was in memphis
five weeks ago maybe he was in memphis
and we were messaging and uh he was
gonna come here to
be a guest on the podcast and i said
don't come man like it's just i felt bad
he was gonna
have to come you know four hours or
something i think he was taking the bus
and i just said we'll do it later we'll
do it when i'm down near you in florida
where he lived
um
and it just bums me out like i just
i i don't know maybe if i had been in a
space where i was just more like
yes yes saying yes to things you know or
just
maybe if my spirits have been high that
day not that i would have saved him or
done anything but we just would have had
a time you know he just
maybe there would have been one extra
moment of somebody saying yes
i care you know welcome come
in you know be a part of
uh
so
man he struggled man he has so many
hilarious stories i hope to one day get
someone in here who knows a lot of the
stories
of eric myers um
he had a unique voice hollywood missed
him they
they missed him
he was just i mean he was from another
planet
i would see him in baton rouge we would
work together we worked together down in
florida captain brian's off the hook
and you gotta do comedy and they're
doing cracking their [ __ ]
oysters and slaughtering uh octopus or
octopi right next to you
you [ __ ] telling a joke and they're
[ __ ] telling an octopus his last
rites you know
they're over there electric electric
chair and clams and you trying to rattle
off a riddle you know
and we had to switch each time and we
had he one of us would go first one was
a second i did not want to go second
i did not want to go second because that
means i had to go after him
and he came down to baton rouge once and
i would see him in texas
uh anyway he's just really talented so
i'm just kind of rambling and just kind
of lamenting at the same time
um but i hope you go check out his stuff
he has a special on youtube
that was i think shot at the laugh
factory or somewhere
um but man he was so good
but man he battled with the devil
i mean he just had it inside of him
so anyway sorry to be such a downer look
i'm sorry to be the down
here but brady how do i stay i
just the only thing that i know
which hasn't always kept me sober but it
has kept me alive
is that i try to communicate with others
um
and contrary action you don't feel like
doing something do it
when you don't do it that's the thing
you'll surprise yourself then you'll
realize how much you're capable of
but i'm not trying to preach at you man
i love you bro and keep your head up dog
and um praise god man gang [ __ ]
um all right
i think we got to the end of this
episode pretty decently we made it
anyway that's important
and we'll close out on this
uh thank you guys as always
you know and if you're struggling keep
your head up and be good to yourself be
good to someone else
um just don't feel alone
you know but yeah the separation that
this whole thing is caused
uh
oh it's a lot it's a lot man
so if you know somebody that struggled
go spend some time with them
give them that extra call a little thing
just i'm thinking of you
now you know make a plan with them
um anyway y'all be good to yourselves
man we'll go out on matthew
qazi all runs
in the family
[Music]
it's out of my hands and in my blood
it's just a matter of time
there ain't no stopping the sailing
baby
you can pray for mercy but it won't come
[Music]
true
it's just a matter of time
there ain't no stopping this
you